and then he busted at a rifle started
walking around shooting people and then
like he shot somebody's like parent and
then the kid was like crying holy you're
just sitting there all smuggy your pasta
yeah what kind of pasta was it oh it was
good oh shoot I don't know yeah tell us
about the pasta
[Music]
you guys remember in like science class
or anything like that you had to build
you know like
um different either balloon race cars
egg drops random I mean egg drops or
whatever what are egg drops if you build
you build like a a craft for your egg to
sit safely and then you drop it from a
store I've never heard of that if you
could uh so everybody's like coming in
it's like a physics thing everybody's
coming in like putting it in pillows
putting like paper mache around it I
made ice cream
I remember one of the things uh for us
was we had to build like a balloon race
car where you like yeah and you know
there's actual races and science
classroom and stuff like that pretty
cool um it just reminded me of this
particular story right here because this
right here
that is very very
cream of the crop when it comes to
engineering a Chef Boyardee race car
whoa are those skateboard wheels it
looks like skateboard wheels they pick
12 bearings too yeah all right what I
can't even tell them Chef boy already
can with four wheels attached okay yeah
it's really not that crazy except for
the fact that this kid like put it out
in the street and then it shut down the
entire Chicago Street because somebody
thought it was a bomb and police had to
come in oh God no shut down the whole
street it was kind of like a bomb and
I'll say rearrest Richard Jewel does
that really bomb ask it's a chef Boyard
you can yeah sometimes you can make that
no bomb I guess so suspicious packaging
right yeah and it just left there right
you know how like at the airport and
stuff you get there like if you see
something say something if anybody
leaves a suspicious bag like what is a
suspicious bag bomb sightings are like
swatting it's like they'll never not
take it seriously so even if someone
just thinks it's a bomb like they don't
ask for like yeah like if you say bomb
in a plane then they have to like
[__] follow every protocol anywhere
or hostage or something like that
they'll just come it's crazy so you
could just call you could just call bomb
threats that's how swattings always
happen
not getting trouble though no but if you
faked it you're in big trouble what if
you didn't know what if you called on
the chef already oh that's different I
thought you were saying like just going
like what if you call it a pay phone
dude
if you don't want to go that day that's
all you gotta do yeah so if you have a
test that day let's press star 69 what's
that block number oh yeah block your
number God star 82.69 yeah that's the
Callback that's the call back this this
one to block man all the star codes
hika's been telling me about like they
have lockdown drills because you know
like we had we grew up growing up we had
like earthquake drills like hiding under
the desk so you know in case you're like
active shoot or whatever so they try to
like roll the cover what happened is it
still duck rolling cover yeah for
earthquake same exact drill for the
drills I think to not scare the kids too
much because because he's in
kindergarten so they're like so
sometimes there might be like an adult
that's not supposed to be on campus no
way to say it so when they are on campus
this is what you do and they like they
go to a specific room and all that and
they go and sometimes they're wolves
that come on campus too so oh so I guess
they make it where it's like it could be
a a person or it could be a crazy animal
so like that way I think the kids they
like I don't know if it's more fun or
like they're more incentivized that's
lying but did they because like this is
what we do when there's like a person or
a wolf you're like what the
a freaking werewolf costume technically
that's both
Duck and Roll like an adventure sphere
huh yeah and then he was like that's
kind of really cute yeah like tomorrow
tomorrow is gonna be locked down the
real person is coming like a real person
is not coming he goes they said it is
I'm like the real person if they were
coming they're not gonna tell you so I
was like if they're telling you you have
no chance yeah the lockdown is going on
tomorrow you guys are practicing it he
goes no no papa you don't know tomorrow
is the real lockdown the real person's
coming but it could be a wolf it could
be a wolf too yeah say that to 911
because we're all believers here that's
what how do I say that to 911 you want
me to open a calendar
do not get the reference in the concept
of it no I go it's a wolf or no open the
calendar and I want to see what happens
what are you gonna say to 9 11. I don't
know make a voice note following your
guys's rules anything's wrong not our
rule because they were told that you
know there's gonna be training and [__]
like that so they're you know they're
all the fun oh [__] we're gonna whatever
oh is that what they said yeah so when
it actually happened everybody was very
under the impression 911 calendars are
[__] sick what the [__] to Porsche
911.
I didn't know that was gonna [__] pop
up look at this [__] sick ass Porsche
dude I kind of want a 911 calendar now
my friend who works at crypto.com said
that like if you leave a back you could
get a whole game canceled by leaving the
wrong box or backpack at the front or
anywhere in the stadium unclaimed
because they will take it super serious
I would imagine yeah yeah it's a public
space where you could just Target a ton
of people so like like everybody that
works there is trained to report like
seeing things like that even no matter
what their job is even hot dog people
yeah everybody if there's a bag and like
no it's like nobody's bag then they
immediately like have to check it you
know what's crazy at almost every like
Mass person event there's like snipers
and stuff like uh on our side like cops
on our side I was like what of course
where do we not go it's like the amount
of like police and City resources that
need to happen for large size events we
don't even know about they're just like
people just like doing things behind the
scenes keeping people safe yeah yeah
because in case there's another weird
guy like that has his own rifle that guy
will take him out did they have that at
the freaking country music probably did
oh I went to the Long Beach Grand Prix
and there was an active shooter there I
was I was eating freaking what the hell
yeah and some dude was walking around
the rifle and I'm like oh it's
interesting and then freaking SWAT team
like I was there right when it all
happened and freaking SWAT team like
this is crazy yeah we were about to
leave I was like wait is this guy still
that large or is he did and then
somebody said oh yeah he's down it's
like cool let's keep eating wow we I I
haven't they didn't shoot anybody what
up yeah he shot uh he shot he got shot
and then he shot two or three other
people how recent was this uh Long Beach
Grand Prix like a month ago like last
month dude you hear about this I don't
know it was on the yeah well I just mean
like it's crazy how you don't hear about
the stuff as frequently anymore in your
own like neighborhood oh yeah it didn't
it didn't really fit any agenda so it's
just like a like an older Mexican dude
and then he busted at a rifle started
walking around shooting people and then
like he shot somebody's like parent and
then the kid was like crying holy you're
just sitting there all smug eating your
pasta yeah what kind of pasta was it oh
it was good oh shoot I don't know yeah
tell us about the pasta bow tie pasta
with like this creamy cheesy sauce and
like some steak on the top nice pasta
was good what's your favorite kind of
pasta right
[Laughter]
pretty type an active shot
nice
I'm a singer so was the last time you
guys called a bomb threat right
now now I can't wait to like think of
different scenarios where I can call on
a bumper I mean it's like pulling a fire
alarm at your school and I just said it
way more yeah and it's super hard to get
away with it no you gotta press star 69
or whatever they'll never know because
then like you it's a federal level so
they really are gonna look for you
whatever dude it's not a big deal they
have Federal warnings on it's disease
there's a copy a movie that's a federal
federal crime go to jail for that that's
it that's true
that's a site for those you know which
one what which one do you use you
actually recently I went to go look for
that site and it all got taken down
which one was it get taken off quick if
this one was like up for a while I
forgot the name was like HD TMO or
something oh there's another one's way
better Steve put me on it yeah all right
he fights I have to go through like
three different websites I got some I
got some links you don't just go to buy
the ESPN app
we don't talk about buying and moving
ESPN app reviews are like 85. yeah but
you buy the you buy like service to the
app and then you still have to buy each
fight yeah yeah that's what I'm saying
damn even on the apps we we still use a
site to skip the because sometimes you
can watch them for free on the App if
it's like a little uh what is like a
smaller car yeah the smaller one yeah
we'll still go on the website just
because we don't want to go through the
app you want to donate to the site yeah
so you get users they get they get paid
with banner ads it's user funded yeah
support the community dude why the ads
always pornography because they're
they'll probably get the most clicks you
know what's crazy what I'm thinking
about right now there were a lot of
little toy bombs as kids that you could
buy remember really yeah like out of the
ice cream truck like you can get like
even that little thing that those
poppers yeah the poppers the thing where
you squeeze it and it's just baking soda
vinegar and then the bag just explodes
what I was thinking like a little sperm
yeah they were called bomb bags yeah
those are cool I used to put them I used
to put them in the locker you know the
locker slits how like every Locker oh
yeah that's how they breathe you just
put them halfway in there and then you
activate it and the [__] ruins someone's
books like every page dude you're a man
dude right I used to love doing that
[__] you're the king of pranks do you go
to random lockers or targeted lockers no
random lockers yeah his Thanos yeah yeah
yeah there's Danny Randy dude that [__]
was like but then I got caught the the
um was it the plant manager or the
groundskeeper guy saw me doing it and
then he made he gave me this whole
lecture about how like you know someone
could have something very meaningful to
them in there and you would have ruined
it and I would yeah like your mom and I
was like I'll never do that again I was
like that's a really cool you're right
you doubled up on the bombs no it's like
I could I could understand that and like
he didn't like yell at me it was just
like you know someone might have a
Sentimental item in there and it's
ruined and I'm like you're right that's
[__] up I'll never do it again
to that day I retired